is hugely important that if you have a
dream that you have to dedicate their
life to it I had caused this kid to
throw his life away that that feeling of
regret turned into a sort of a fear of
how much power I had
what's that believe nation at seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world now I started the
mentor me series to try to hang your own
people who've done a lot more than us
and hopefully by spending a little more
time with them some of their views or
attitudes their mindsets seeps into us
to help us become the best version of
ourselves so today we're going to learn
five powerful life lessons from Will
Smith mentor me will
[Music]
let's kick it up with lesson number one
face your fears something that probably
a lot of people don't know about me I
don't put the ocean the ocean is like
the ultimate woman she's beautiful and
she will nourish you but she will tear
you to shreds also the ocean is my worst
fear I don't know what it is or where it
came from but there's something about
not being able to breathe
I've tried snorkelling before and I was
hyperventilating
my 50th birthday is this year I just
wasn't gonna go into the back nine of my
life without having attacked my fear of
the ocean so we're about to scuba dive
the Great Barrier Reef you know I've
never scuba divin scoubidou scuba I
never been scuba divers before so we're
taking a boat ride out and we go through
a storm
[Music]
probably 25 years old in my mind I would
be here one day so I'm ready I'm ready
this is stupid hi I'm not going is it
okay to punch sharks in the face back up
with your shark ass back up with your
shark ass
shucks ass back up I got it
[Music]
[Applause]
the question isn't can you handle the
situation the question is can you handle
your mind can you manage the thoughts
and the emotions that are trying to
poison your progress
forget managing the situation
manage your mind training your mind to
sit calmly in the eye of the storm
lesson number two dedicate your life to
your dream was 94 something like that
they were open to Planet Hollywood I
found myself in a room with Arnold
Schwarzenegger Bruce Willis and sly and
I was like oh my god I got these three
guys in the room and I was like okay I
want to be the biggest movie star in the
world and I need you guys to tell me how
to do it and Arnold Schwarzenegger he
said he said if your movie is only big
in America it doesn't matter you'll be a
movie star only when you're a movie star
in every country in the world you have
to travel you have to go you have to
meet the people thanks for the tip fax
son fax that became the way that I
started looking at movies I wanted to be
in every country in the world in that
part of my career I refused to do
anything that wasn't in the best
interest of the goal I had set for
myself and there's probably a 12 year
period of my life where I did take a
train I have a drink where I didn't go
out on the weekends that I was so set on
my goal it created a serious circle of
protection and
elevation because I refuse to do
anything that wasn't in my best interest
it's hugely important that if you have a
dream that you have to dedicate your
life to it and that every hour of every
day has to be dedicated to bring it into
fruition to things that you dream about
listen number three decide to inspire
people I went to a Catholic school up to
eighth grade with all white kids and
probably two or three black kids but if
you know predominantly white school and
then I went to my neighborhood high
school in ninth grade that was 99% black
kids so the first day that I walk in to
ninth grade I walked into the lunchroom
and you know it's like five hundred kids
and for to this day I don't know why I
did this I'm sure it was because I was I
was nervous and you know I got that I
have a thing with fear I don't like
being scared so I'm sure I was I walked
in I looked around and I said scuse me
can I have your attention can I have
your attention please
he's here he's here right now thank you
thank you people who got to looking and
there was just one dude and he was
sitting there and he looked up to me
said man don't nobody get that you here
right and I said hey just give me ten
minutes your girl going care right and
he was like and you got to watch that
not that not is not a good night he was
like
and I was like okay so I went some
walking up the steps we're out of the
lunchroom and I forgot about it
so we're gone and I'm walking up the
steps and he had taken one of those
combination locks and he put the lock in
the palm of his hand and put his but the
the loop around his knuckle and he was
holding the lock in his hand and as I
was walking up the steps he cracked me
in the side of my head with the lot and
I went down I was out I don't remember
nothing I still got the lump on my head
you can't see it cuz I got my hair but I
stood like there's still a lump so I
remember I fell down and I hit my mouth
on the steps all of that stuff you know
so I went up so I'm in the principal's
office all attacked the police come and
I got the ice on my lips and I'm sitting
in the principal's office and my father
comes in he sees me and you know I'm
telling the story now the police are
there and I remember I saw this kid they
put him in handcuffs and took him out of
the school and I'm looking sitting in
the principal's office and I'm watching
the police take him out and put him in
the back of a police car and I just
couldn't believe it had escalated to a
kid being removed from from school and I
was laying in my bed that night and I
was just feeling like Shh and I had the
recognition that I had caused this kid
to throw his life away
right and he was kicked out of school
and I never knew what happened to him
but I have a sense that it didn't go
well beyond there and I felt a deep
sense of regret and a deep sense that I
had caused an emotion in a person that
made them do that and that that feeling
of regret turned into a sort of a fear
of how much power I had and I was like
everything I say and do has that kind of
effect on other human beings and in that
moment I decided that I would never walk
into a room and do anything other than
inspire and uplift and enlighten people
and help people to be the greater
versions of themselves and I would never
do anything that would cause people to
or to rile up the darkest dirtiest parts
of people I only wanted to enliven and
enlighten and inspire and I remember
laying in my bed that night and I made
that promise to myself and I made that
promise to God and it's something that
has completely shaped how I approach
people how I approach moments how I walk
into rooms how I deal with every human
being on this earth lesson number four
never chase money
[Music]
about
my experience has been and then you'll
learn how to make money
with us when I changed careers I was
never changing to some
the burning I was changed into something
I love right and that to me that's
really the only way to keep the passion
if you have two choices one is on a
piano and another one bowling
we can make more money bullying but you
love playing the piano more you got to
play the piano it's like you'll tear
yourself apart if you're not doing the
thing
life
right now there's something that she
loved more than everybody and listen
number five the last one before a very
special bonus clip is you have to work
hard there was a moment when I was about
nine years old
and I was at the resurrection Baptist
Church where that was the church I went
to growing up and my grandmother was
always in charge of all of the recitals
and Easter recitations and all all of
that stuff so I was playing a piano and
I remember my grandmother was standing
back offstage and she put me last in the
show and everything and I had learned
Farrelly's and I was playing for a lease
and I'm going and going and going and
I'd never learned how to end it right so
I was just playing play and play and my
grandmother was standing backstage and I
was looking at plan and that look of
pride and happiness on my grandmother's
face is that's my life force everything
I do I just need that look you know in
my wife's eyes and my daughter's eyes
it's just
you have realized and I've realized very
very young that there's no easy way
around it no matter how talented you are
your talent is going to fail you if
you're not skilled you know if you don't
study if you don't work really hard and
dedicate yourself to being better every
single day you'll never be able to
communicate with with people with your
artistry the way that you want so it's a
that moment I just remember so
distinctly and how good it felt and and
I just thought needed
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Will Smith on how to improve
yourself that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that I want to know what
lesson is most applicable to you what
did you take from this video don't just
watch another video what did you take
from this video they're gonna apply
somehow to your life leave it down in
the comments when you write it down it's
much more likely to actually happen
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
the concept of improving lives runs
through the center of everything I do
and then I realize that the the way to
improve lives is to continually improve
yourself right so with that every every
morning when I when I get out of the bed
you know I I haven't fixed everything in
the world yet so there's always
something to do and in this film I read
an interesting quote the Siddhartha
Gautama the Buddha he said that good
people have to get out of the bed every
day and try to empty the ocean with a
ladle right and I thought that was you
know I knew that was profound and I
paused for a second and I said all right
what the hell is a ladle right right so
there you know I just I touched it on my
iPad is ladle oh it's like a big spoon a
big book okay so try to empty the ocean
with a soup spoon you know as the the
mentality of how you you wake up every
day to try to do good in the world so
for me I'm I'm really driven by
continually trying to elevate my elevate
my mind and elevate my spirit and care
for my body and to be able to love as
many people as effectively as as
possible with this mystery of life that
I've been given raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
people passion
[Music]
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's suppose to mean I don't ever
give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated
hey believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten gross a
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
Clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link in description
for details